such a great pleasure to have you here
Evander thanks for joining us thank you
well does this fight have the potential
to give boxing a new life in America I
mean popularity you could argue in the
sport has been waning a little bit
what's your take yes I truly believe
that it can I think that it is I'm
because everybody boxes back home free
television now you got a lot of people
saying i would like to hell when I'm
payday that Mayweather and you're going
you have your seat already yes and
you're actually working with an auction
on eBay right now to give a seed sitting
next to you during the the match tell us
about it well we have this despite
foresight and it's a charity thing that
you get an opportunity for you you get
an opportunity to sit beside me you get
a free free plane trip and get to get
some quest bars for a whole year it's a
lot of great good things in it what
about your work at the madison square
garden because talking about crazy
awesome fights maximum square garden is
going to be home this weekend to
Klitschko I say that right yes vs.
Jennings Todd could talk to us about the
big fights there I mean you had that
huge one well here's a heavyweight
championship fight and they get a chance
to get a chance to fight in Madison
Square Garden which is a great thing and
so people should be excited about it but
the other fighters kind of you know but
this is to fight and so Jenny have
opportunity to beat Klesko are you gonna
be there at that fight be there um my
Tyson sued Don King saying that he was
cheated out of some earnings um what do
you think are you on board with that I
mean did you feel like you were cheated
with Don King like Mike Tyson did what
no uh it didn't happen to me unfortunate
things happen two fighters but its all
depend the Fighting's have who do they
have in a corner do they have a good
attorney and
that it's just hard to let one person
control everything and speaking of
fighting you are gonna be fighting Mitt
Romney yes what for what tell us why
would you fight in the gerotor video
it's a hundred thousand one hundred
thousand people may get the opportunity
get that on tape back we'll get the
opportunity to die side back in and
which is it's a charity thing and is it
works I mean he's really he looks like
he's working out I mean what do you
think you'd think that he's gonna take
you well yeah well you know he would do
a great job in you know I'm gonna do a
great job but you at the end we all win
we all win they gonna pull your punches
well what you're not I'm not gonna put
you know I'm it is something that'll
work the boat alright so I think you're
gonna give me a little boxing lesson now
if you don't mind we take off my shoes
here so back when I was fit I might have
thrown a punch or two well we actually
got a little cracked lift once that was
okay then well but you know the thing is
it this way right here cuz your reason
why you want to have your hands up
because you know what if i swing you
lease your block yeah you're like yeah
like that but you know you know how you
you doing this jab can do this one yeah
no no no this one um uh yeah yeah see
I'm looking down look at that you put it
here don't want to okay oh yeah come on
yeah come on oh you good you don't did
this no um not too good uh what about
you some undercuts well you don't need
the uppercut you don't you you want that
jab in that right hand cuz you know what
you wanna you want to get them out that
person that when you uppercut because
you uppercuts for people who have a
spirits cuz you know what you had to do
you had to drop your hand and hit the
person up a cup that mean that if you
drop the hand that person hit you haha I
could could knock you out thank you from
my lesson I feel like I earn something
today all right